[Music] All
right, everyone's images are all set Alright, it's
burning
[Music] It's
done
An image illustration of a secret base
I wrote this in one night
Various images came to my mind
Selfie is amazing, this house, the
universe
It's not a tree house, it's more like a
tree town I've got a lot of images
coming up, there
's even a roller coaster and a Ferris wheel around the tree.
However, I've come up with a lot of different images, and that
selfie's illustration is really wonderful.
So, how
about extracting the good points of each and
combining them?
Well
, this rocket tree house is certainly impossible,
but I think you can make a swing using tires
.
I ca
n't
throw it from the house onto the roof of the material.